hey we're stuffed with clouds this
morning i tell you that the skies are
overstuffed so we've got overcast skies
the color is pretty much all gone but we
did do a really good time lapse in fact
let me show you the clouds and sunrise
here were just about 20 25 minutes ago
check this out we rolled all of our
cameras
excuse me rolled a camera on all of our
cameras we recorded
different angles of the valley looking
out to the east as the sun was getting
ready to come up and the color was just
splendiferous if you will for about 15
minutes we saw all this beautiful color
out there and we often get really
colorful sunrises and sunsets here in
the desert when we have clouds at those
times so really really was pretty if you
have any pictures you want to share with
us if you went out took some you can
always do that at pixpx 8newsnow.com
we'd love to share them with our viewers
so again the clouds holding in a little
bit of the warmth temperatures really
haven't changed too much over the course
of the morning a lot of 50s around 40s
up at lea canyon the winds finally
settled down up there so that allowed
temperatures to fall back a little bit
47 in indian springs 52 in mesquite
we've got 58 in boulder city and
laughlin just barely a little milder
than that at 61 but some cool 30s up in
caliente 50 at tonopah 49 in reno so
temperatures not as chilly as we've been
but again a lot of that's because of the
clouds holding in some of the overnight
warmth and from yesterday so we've got
snow showers through the intermountain
west cold canadian air that's still
pouring into the upper midwest around
the great lakes and through the ohio
valley today they're going to be wearing
big coats around those areas those
temperatures just won't make it out of
the 40s for daytime highs so we can't
complain too much cold front will
continue to advance south into our area
that's later tonight into early tomorrow
and that will open the door for even
cooler weather for us for the rest of
the week 74 for the high if we can get
these clouds out of here soon enough at
least by midday to have some good
afternoon sunshine overnight mostly
clear skies so tomorrow morning a little
cool cooler than this morning with low
50s even some valley neighborhoods in
the upper 40s and that trend we keep
through the weekend really morning temps
in the 40s for the most part more clouds
by friday saturday you can see low 70s
to near 70 degrees into the weekend with
even some 60's showing up as we head
towards turkey day next week